gang big announcement huge announcement
i'm talking bigger than my stomach
or kippy's forehead ru garbage is going
live
thursday september 24th at 7 p.m at the
punch line
in philadelphia pennsylvania we're doing
our first live show in our hometown
with special local philly legendary goon
mr mike rainey and it's going to be a
good time so get your tickets now
september 24 7 pm at the punch line
we'll see you there hey gang it's your
old pals uncle hank and kippy just want
to thank you for tuning in to ru garbage
yeah guys make sure you subscribe that
way you get the episode as they come out
you can also go to gasdigitalnetwork.com
use promo code ayg to get bonus content
and get the episodes before they come
out and hd streaming
do it yeah welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
kevin ryan and h foley
[Music]
baby hey everybody out there and welcome
back to everybody's favorite
new podcast this is are you garbage the
show where we sit down with your
favorite comedians
and find out they go up classy or if
they're complete trash
i'm your host age foley coming at you on
a glorious absolutely
beautiful september day here in the east
village
of new york city at the gas digital
network here in the big studio
we are alive and well folks don't let
the [ __ ] fake news fool you
we're hanging in there like tippy's
rogaine prescription
my co-host as you know as you love
coming at you
right next to me he's got his laptop in
front of him he's sitting there looking
pretty
gang the next time reaching for a best
pal do yourself a favor
you make it a kippy give it up for kevin
james ryan everybody
hey gang everybody knows you don't need
a prescription for rogaine you need one
for
propecia which should be arriving at my
door today
shout out to keeps.com
up everybody thanks so much for tuning
in uh as always please make sure you
rate review subscribe on itunes
uh full video available on youtube you
can subscribe there as well
also if you want to uh help out the pod
you can subscribe to gas digital network
use promo code ayg you get to save a
couple of bucks every month
we get to wet our beaks at the end of
the month it's a win-win for everybody
so [ __ ] do it we appreciate the
support so far
yes sir and gang we could not and i mean
could not be more excited to have a
special guest here with us today this
kid is an absolute [ __ ]
get from out there in la la land he is a
very successful
stand-up comedian and actor you have
seen him in i'm dying up here
crashing historical roasts corporate
business doing pleasure
lights out with david spade funny dance
show what's your [ __ ] deal
kill tony rose battle and of course
let's not forget
2010's dance cam
slam so he's got a little bit of cash on
him
he's been working for a while but the
big question about his mind today is he
garbage
ladies and gentlemen give us a nice big
round of applause for the one
the only mr jeremiah watkins everybody
what's up guys how you doing what's up
man thanks for doing the show i heard
i heard that you guys were wet and beaks
and you know i came in
he's got quite a beak on him he does
yeah let's do it man let's go
buddy you look great you sound great
thanks so much for doing the show we're
happy to uh to have you here where are
you now you
know you're out in l.a you on the coast
oh man
another day in l.a yep out on the west
coast
no longer the best coast no far
from it far from it now good how did new
york and la both [ __ ] to bed at the
exact same [ __ ] time that's not fair
yeah who kansas or somewhere the middle
of the country is [ __ ] killing it
right now
yeah that is stink that's that's where
i'm from and uh
kansas actually yeah yeah you're from
kansas
they're doing okay they're doing okay i
went in
nothing crazy but everything's more
relaxed there uh than
obviously out on the coast but yeah
that's where i'm from is
kansas city so so so tell us the whole
story about growing up uh
where near kansas i grew up in a city
called
overland park uh until i was um
uh like in eighth grade i i moved a
little bit farther south in overland
park and then um
when my parents got divorced i moved to
olathe
kansas and growing up
there a little bit about me if people
don't know i
i went to a private christian school
growing up
oh [ __ ] and uh all the way through
the divorce until eighth grade so like
the marital problems started happening
when i went to public school so you know
i blame it on the public sales it's your
fault yeah
it's my fault uh but yeah um grew up
like in a suburban
uh kind of area we
i lived on like a busy intersection
growing up and then
later on lived on like a classic like
kansas cul-de-sac
kind of thing yeah oh yeah
right brothers and sisters what was the
situation
older brother younger sister so i'm
right in the middle
my brother is three years older and my
sister is two years younger than me two
years younger so when the divorce hit
who who did it hit the hardest you or
your sister
oh um i think
probably my brother and my sister
because that's
when they started like partying
from i went from being told my entire
life that drugs and alcohol were very
bad and then
i saw everybody around me start to do it
when
the marriage started to fall apart the
wheels on the bus start coming off let's
party yeah
uh huh it's like getting some selling on
the titanic [ __ ] [ __ ] it
i walked back uh one one day and my uh
in the backyard
and my sister and my mom were doing
mushrooms together and
what my mom said that i looked like i
was in a field
playing a guitar and i was i had nothing
in my hands
woodstock what the [ __ ] happening so
jesus christ
your parents are ultra christian
conservative would you say that
growing up growing up yes very much so
yeah they were pretty conservative to
yeah the conservative christian yeah
then
you got a divorce your parents got a
divorce in the eighth grade you're in
the eighth grade
i went to public school in the eighth
grade and they got a like they finalized
the divorce when i was
my junior year in high school so
basically like over those three years
things started like happening yeah yeah
and that's when like my brother my
sister started acting out
like compared to like you know we were
all like beaver cleaver kids
before that and then with things got
like kind of tumultuous and then it just
you know all over the place
dude that's a [ __ ] are you garbage
first truman with mom
when you walked in on the shroom fest in
your backyard
uh i think i was 17 or 18 at this point
and my sister was probably
15 or so she would have been yeah should
have been 15 or 16.
who scored the mushrooms hurry your mom
i think my mom got them from a friend
uh i believe it's a hard left turn out
out of the church
i'd say yeah yeah for sure like i didn't
see my
yeah we we stopped going to church like
as a family like uh
like around that time because it used to
be like we were like a three day a week
family
we would go sunday morning sunday
evening and wednesday evening
so we were like real hardcore it's a
it's a lot
a lot of tithes that dude
i never really met anybody that did
three days a week that's crazy
yeah it was intense uh and sometimes
like
it would even be like you would go to
sunday school before
the actual sunday message on sunday so
it's
like you were your boy was doing two
days back in the day
back in my day yeah back in my day we
did two days you know
now this wasn't catholic this is this is
christian so what
what yeah what exactly it was uh
or whatever protestant christian uh and
it was a sect
called uh church of god holiness which
is
a more strict version of baptist that
sounds like end of the world [ __ ] right
there
well at this church the women were
looked down upon if they wore makeup or
jewelry
and they all wore like dresses
like if you wore pants that was like hip
and edgy so my mom was like the
the cool hip even before she was a
[ __ ] wife
she was a wild child she showed me yeah
exactly
damn pave in the way
so it was like that holy [ __ ] did you
what did you guys do for uh the
eucharist as we call it was it just a
wafer
like just a regular oh like communion
uh we did um
it was not alcohol it was uh
it was like these kind of crackers and
it was uh it was like welch's grape
juice i believe
because i went to i went to catholic
school my whole life but for a year
we went to like this eastern european
catholic school
and we had to go to church every morning
before class i swear to god
they wouldn't give you a little like a
little host it was a little tiny piece
of bread
that was soaked in wine and i'm [ __ ]
six years old i'm [ __ ] crippled
first period no get out of here i'm
telling you it was some kind
it's a way to get the party started
you were upset it wasn't garlic bread
could you soak one of these red lobster
biscuits
in the wine no not today i don't need
yours i got my own product
hey pops you got a cheddar biscuit back
there huh forget about it
hey can i get a cheddar baby brisket can
i get an olive on bread stick i just
want to
kiss a little why not you for the christ
that i'm about to consume
let me tell you something you could say
what you want about those casual dining
facilities but they're free bread
and [ __ ] cheddar biscuits and
whatever they got they ain't
too shabby you get them at the beginning
of the shift when they're coming out of
the oven
good night
yeah i'm a i'm a six basket minimum kind
of guy
lobster yeah keep them coming [ __ ] out
of that
keep them coming that's literally what
my mom always says it's like she'll grab
the waitress he's like yeah baby
keep them coming that's like a stock
broker ordering a martini
like hey keep he's coming so so who did
you live with
who did you live with after the divorce
did you stay with your mom
i stayed with my mom where did you where
did your dad go
my brother went to live out with my dad
uh oh really and yeah yeah he went
to live with him um in farther south
kansas uh in a city called stillwell
which is like
even more that's like where you start
getting like
a little bit more kansas you know what i
mean like where it's like more
a lot more fields and stuff like that
and more of the stereotypical stuff that
you see
like uh in road trip movies when they go
through kansas that's all western kansas
that's like
no man's land that's it's not very
populated
when you start going farther south like
that to places like stillwell you keep
going
um it's much more populated now but like
you know 10 15 years ago when
when i was in that area it was there's
hardly anything out there except like
houses and stuff like that not like the
glitz and glamour of eastern kansas i
would imagine
eastern kansas uh we have high speed
internet there yeah really rolling the
red carpet out for you it's the paris i
know
did your dad stay in the church or did
your dad
did your dad go rogue as well or did he
stay religious
um he for a while
went rogue and he was not religious he
wasn't um
he he like was in party mode for a while
like he was he would
he would go to bars and uh and he would
uh uh
so this was all picking different women
at bars and stuff like that
yeah i think so man i think that you
know you put so much pressure on
something and
and i think that you you want to put out
an image for so long i think that if you
don't get
your yayas out that eventually it kind
of
you know implodes it's a self-implode
kind of thing where if you're not doing
things like self-care along the way
and getting stuff out of your system
getting those demons out of your body
every once in a while that's what's
going to happen yeah all right come on
yeah where's the xanax
wow that is a [ __ ] tail and that's
that your brother went to live with your
dad
that would have [ __ ] me up more than a
divorce if my brother would have split
that would have been like what you're
leaving too what the [ __ ]
yeah well it's kind of hard because i
think that my brother
felt because my my little sister and i
went with my mom and i think as a as a
brother more of it like his son duty i
think he felt like he owed it to my dad
that like
not all the kids you know what i mean
sure like he's gotta he's gotta
play mediator a little bit pretty classy
move yeah i'll tell you that
i mean yeah you're taking one for the
team absolutely i think he did that yeah
for my dad to just be like
so my dad wouldn't be like oh my you
know yeah my wife's gone and all my kids
are gone so
yeah strong move by my brother for sure
i remember when my parents i got i was
super i was like three or four and
my parents told me and my dad's like
anybody any of the kids want to come
with me today because like he was
leaving like
he was leaving the house that we were
like we're living in
he's like anybody want to come with me
and i remember like dude do you think
i'm gonna leave my [ __ ]
[ __ ] house with all my toys and [ __ ]
[ __ ] hats
forget my name dude what are you talking
about yeah
dude you just came in my mom that was
good
i don't even know you holy [ __ ] now did
your mom and dad stay
you know like in touch or were they
friendly or they're
they're friendly now for a while it was
like messy where they couldn't even see
each other and stuff like that
and uh would you do like the two
christmases and back and forth like
thanksgiving here thanksgiving there
yeah man
yeah i um and it happened late like i
moved out to la
when i was 20
years old damn that's wrong yeah yeah
man
i am so i've been out here in la for i
just hit my 11 years in july
and uh so i kind of got out
while some of that stuff was going on
you know what i mean like when things
were like kind of weird or whatever but
i i still do you know we still do the
the multiple holiday things
when i go back you know we have to
schedule times for
christmas over at mom's christmas over
at dads and they both have significant
others now and
you know one of them has like their set
of kids and it's a
it's a big ol happy yeah
yeah who who who had more kids your mom
or your dad
uh my mom's husband he has a couple
songs
so you have step siblings yeah brady
bunch yeah yeah for sure
i got yeah what's the rule on that can
you hook up can you legally hook up with
your step sister i know you can on
pornhub apparently
i mean
[Laughter]
the kid making moves at thanksgiving i
like it
um all right so let's play a little game
called are you garbage
uh jeremiah we're going to ask you a
series of questions to determine whether
you're trash or not
answer the questions openly honestly and
to the best
of your ability you are not being judged
in any way
uh except for the thousands of people
listening to this but
rest assured you're talking to two
pieces of trash yeah we're different
from outside philadelphia
you're in good company so i gotta tell
you i
i waited a long time to respond to your
booker's
email for the invite for this podcast
yeah because
i know i'm garbage but i didn't know if
i was comfortable yet
having other people be like oh no he's
for sure garbage
i know that deep down yeah like i had to
overcome the obstacle of coming on the
show i'm like all right here we go this
is it you're facing yeah you're facing a
lot in the mirror right well if you were
worried about that i would have
i would have kept the uh the mom
dropping acid on a wednesday with your
little sister
closer to the jets yeah he dropped out
of like minute four oh
that's what happens everybody comes on
you don't want to tell us nothing but
you're showing us
everything listen i know how these
youtube algorithms work i'm looking out
for you guys you got to hook these
people early on man you don't want to be
a snooze fest over here
got to represent out here you're
bringing the goods baby we
appreciate it all right so when do you
think i'm going to give you the option
because you have a you have a couple of
stages here
you know as far as as life goes growing
up when would you like us to kind of
center the questions on would you like
to go
pre-divorce when the whole family's
together or would you like to go
post-divorce when you were living with
your mom because post-divorce it sounds
like the wheels fell off a little bit
i mean we could do it around
post-divorce but
i i think it's gonna yeah it'll be it'll
probably be more garbagey
around around that time so okay okay but
let's let's touch base before that
let's do something a little base before
that let's start out with a couple of
basic questions that we like to ask
let's go pre-divorce when you guys are
all living together as a happy family
okay
what was the name of the street that you
that you that you grew up on what was
the name of that that street
lamar avenue
that's trash man anytime it's named
after a guy it's banned
[Laughter]
lamar jackson boulevard
my friend lived on london boulevard it's
not even a famous guy it's just like oh
it's steve down i'm on steve boulevard
down the ship
alan martin away um the
the ave is nice you live on an ave
that's pretty classy but lamar
ab and you said that was that was a
pretty uh heavily
heavily trafficked a heavily trafficked
area
um yeah i think like we grew up like
very middle class and it was one of
those things where we always
lived above our means do you know what i
mean
like i like that we were we were peaking
towards like like we're on the bottom of
middle class where we're like
we're not poverty like every everybody's
like working in the family to get by but
we're
living paycheck to paycheck kind of
thing yeah yeah
um okay and that house on lamar avenue
was it a single family home or townhouse
duplex what was it it was uh i think
it's
it was called like a split uh level
split level
but yeah but it was just you guys in the
in the building right there wasn't
it wasn't like connected to another
family yeah okay yeah so a single family
split level home
gotcha i grew up at a california split
level
pretty cool that's philly for dirtbag
about 10 grand off the asking price
okay did you have uh did you have a
garage
we did uh but you could only
park the car on one side okay why what
was on the other side
freaking just stuff dude boxes and [ __ ]
yeah
yeah like workspace and stuff like that
yeah a big question on the podcast we
like to talk about the garage fridge lot
we just had the annual
uh first annual garage fridge contest on
are you garbage
to see who had the shittiest or
classiest garage fridge
um did you guys have a second
refrigerator in the home
no because um i always thought as a kid
if you had
the the second fridge that you were
loaded yeah
of course that's what kids think yeah
yeah yeah
so we never had that we didn't have a
mini fridge we didn't have any kind of
extra fridge but we had something
that you guys will appreciate that we it
was called the y2k pantry
and um
we had a whole closet in the basement
that had like ramen
noodles and canned food and gallons of
water
and guns and different stuff like that
and it was all
like like end of day's time you know
yeah
yeah they were waiting for the [ __ ]
rapture
and then that didn't happen and your mom
was like [ __ ] it crack open the pill
bottle let's [ __ ] do this
wow that i think you might be our first
that's our first
prepper yeah that's our first doomsday
prepper uh
compartment so what did you do what did
you guys do with all that food when you
moved out
well ramen you lived there for a while
no we lived there for a while where my
mom would just be like
all right go get go get that out of here
so we just lived off it after like we
realized like it wasn't the end of the
world and it wasn't happening like we
lived
off of that food for so many years like
awesome christ yeah what kind of
hardware are we talking about what uh
what kind of kind of stelia toten
anything semi-automatic automatic or
just like hunting rifles
no dude
[Laughter]
there was there was a lot of automatic
and uh semi-automatic uh we had a
semi-automatic uh
nine millimeter there was like a tec-9
that we had uh and then we had uh
we had an sks uh it was like a chinese
assault rifle
and uh some other assault rifles that my
dad had
off and on um we i grew up with guns so
i i like i was given a a double barrel
um 20 gauge shotgun for my 13th birthday
for my
for my grandpa um and uh
i i always just grew up like around a
lot of
different guns like i've shot every like
most of the cool guns that you've seen
in movies i've i've shot most of those
guns
oozy at least like street well the the
nine millimeter was
like that was this he just said he had
the semi-automatic [ __ ]
that's like essentially what a news is
oh really
damn that's pretty i like how you asked
him what kind of what kind of [ __ ]
hardware he's working with like any
they're like oh do you have like a
hunting rifle he rolled his eyes like
the watkins are gonna wait for [ __ ]
the zombie apocalypse with a red rider
bb gun he's like dude what are you
talking about
he's throwing flashbangs and [ __ ] oh
yeah
i got a huffy yeah we 18th birthday this
kid got [ __ ] nickel i like it
yeah we we had like at one point the uh
the atf
uh because my dad uses i don't even know
if i should
yeah yeah if you don't say that i i i
my dad used to sell guns at some point
and i guess like some of the
the paperwork wasn't super legit on some
of them so the atf
i remember coming to our house as a kid
and asking for records of the gun
uh of like of of all those and
uh he had uh he had gotten rid of the
the original paperwork because he knew
that they were coming gee
man hey we had a house fire yeah tough
break yeah sorry all files
exactly i don't know what happened to it
dude that's like wake up
[ __ ] awesome the dichotomy of like
the you know where we go to church three
days a week yet we're also got the atm
barreling down on us
is one of my favorite things in the
world
yeah there's a lot of weird uh
inconsistencies
with my childhood growing up like that
like i look back on like that doesn't
mean
okay well this is okay but that's not
okay that doesn't make sense but all
right whatever
did your family ever have a standoff
with local law enforcement
well like you guys had like the
mattresses up against the windows
everybody was armed the local news was
out there they were trying to talk you
down
no i mean my parents have like you know
i guess
you gotta think about that for a second
i think you're gonna laugh at that
he's actually thinking well there was
that issue with the parking ticket
i mean my pa i i feel like my parents at
some point
have gotten police involved with like
domestic stuff uh so i had to kind of
think
about it uh but nothing nothing like
that
no dude the watkins playing fast and
loose i like
[ __ ] [ __ ] kansas is [ __ ] wide
open i like
this [ __ ] cowboy okay
uh another staple all right we'll
lighten it up a little bit we'll move
away from the semi-automatic weapons for
a moment
um what was the name of the grocery
store that you went to growing up
oh you're gonna love
[Laughter]
chopper i've never heard a supermarket
named after a motorcycle before
wheelie your way to savings price
chopper you thought you were going to
get coronas there just come get a
depressed
come on down to price chopper this
weekend make your own process chop your
own meat
i thought i thought of another one too
uh i'll hit you with this too
i think it's it's a real tell about the
gas station in your town what was the
dominant what was the dominant chain
um because i drove by a gulf the other
day
they're they've they've been hurting for
like 25 years you live near a gulf
you're [ __ ] trash and exxon
what was the what was the gas station
near your place
the main well the main one that we went
to and they're
they're considered the nicer gas
stations out in
the midwest they're quick trips okay and
those are like
those are like the nice ones but i grew
up like next to 7-elevens and
like the one in la we don't have gas
stations attached to the 7-elevens which
i
like and same in new york you guys you
know they're just convenience stores
yeah yeah yes
um so i grew up next to 7-elevens and
sinclair's
and um
petroleum yeah bp's nice it's like a hat
yeah classy
all right that's pretty good because i
know a couple of states
like when we went to hawaii they were
getting gas at bj's
bj's has [ __ ] gas yeah walmart and
chicks yeah people do that now they do
that yeah
[ __ ] that taking over daddy oh that's
true
um i don't know about all that yeah you
can't be buying
hamburgers and [ __ ] gas at the same
time hamburgers socks and gas
have you guys ever been to bucky's in
texas no that's a dope [ __ ] shirt
though
damn that's really cool you got it's
like it's like disneyland
for white trash people
they have they have like every food that
you can think of and it's
actually good and well i mean i just
like food in general
but like they have beef jerky they've
got like ice cream
smoothies like like that's pretty good
desserts
fudge like all this stuff and yeah it's
pretty dope
buggies around texas i love fudge check
out bucky's [ __ ] shout out i like it
use promo code ayg and check it out let
our beak what do you got
um all right this is one i have did you
guys have any uh bumper stickers on the
family car growing up
uh no but we had a personalized uh
license plate on my mom's minivan that
said party mom
oh she was too though so i gotta give it
to her she was a [ __ ] party mom she
what dude
she was the we had i don't know if you
guys had something called a room mother
uh but no in grade school she would
throw
all the parties at like at the end of
the year and she was like our room
mother so it's like
rather than having a class president
it's an adult who coordinates
the different holiday parties throughout
the year and people just knew her as the
party mom did you like that her being
involved in school because sometimes
it's really good and sometimes it's like
get her the [ __ ] out of here
dude my mom is hilarious she's a and
she's just
amazing too she's like she's one of
those people who truly
has never met a stranger dude she she'll
strike up a conversation with anybody
and she's best friends with them with
instagram
yeah that's awesome she throws through a
pretty good party i would imagine
[ __ ] nice cupcakes the whole nine
yards little hawaiian punch
doing it right dude all the all the
frosted cookies
from price chopper come on come on i
love a frosted cookie from the grocery
yeah we picked up on that
especially around the 4th of july a
little red white and blue maybe a
christmas cookie huh not too shabby
maybe uh valentine's day red pink yeah
come on
but the saint patty's day ones are the
best in my opinion yes
why so with milk dude there's something
about the green frosting with like a big
glass of whole milk that's the best
i love that thick but they're shaped in
shamrocks so they're they're easy
they're easy to bite you have four
little four little nice bites right
there
how do you get this is just this is just
turning into his feeding patterns
most episodes my feeding patterns what
are you morgan freeman narrating this
or studying or studying fully that's
pretty good
all right i got one for you we're going
to stay on food here for a minute wanted
to go into the
the watkins kitchen were you a hellman's
mayonnaise family
or a best foods which is i believe the
west coast version of that
or were you garbage and use miracle whip
oh miracle whip all day every day oh
what oh i got a feeling all day this
kid's gonna have the record
i'm telling you right now yeah you might
be like some real midwest trash that
we're gonna
miracle whip it that's tough
dude you're the only person that's ever
said they liked it and like do you still
use it now
um i don't think my wife will let us get
it
see you no you're wrong would you would
you buy it though like if you could like
would you buy it would you still but do
you enjoy it enough to go perfect oh
dude
i have certain things that i like when
i started dating my now wife uh
she literally had to be like you can't
eat like this anymore
it's not this is literally not safe for
you to eat yeah
the way that you're eating anymore like
the amount of like what
and like frozen pizza and stuff and like
all that like stuff in my diet like when
i was like truly a bachelor on my own in
la like
dude i used to have bologna sandwiches
like i i can't eat bologna sandwiches
anymore because i had too many of them
whenever i first he's got a problem
yeah he ate a lifetime of bologna
sandwich in like three years i love a
good balloon
sandwich what uh what's your go-to
frozen pizza that's a big one we're big
frozen frozen pizza guys
red baron is my go-to wow this guy's a
[ __ ] gentleman the
the french bread the oh i'm thinking
stouffer's the red baron's great red
bear
red baron is a [ __ ] home run i'm a
[ __ ]
french bread guy still frustrating is
great digiorno is top
shelf always did you know if i came into
some money
i'll get some of that yeah but red
baron's my go-to it's always like the
lowest
price with the highest quality yep this
guy's a bargain shopper price
shopper taught them real well you ever
have the frozen uh
california pizza kitchen ones i heard
they're really good
pizza kitchens are those are worth the
they're all right but they they cost a
couple dollars extra so i never get them
no that's not even in my like dude i
don't even look at that side of the
freezer when i go
get out yeah i'm like that's out of my
that's out of my social bracket right
here sure um
have you ever bought something worn it
and then returned it to the store
yes absolutely oh what was it what was
the event
um i have done that a lot over the years
with uh costumes
uh uh and different things like um
uh like a pair of binoculars i bought
for a sketch
i guess for like a sketch and stuff like
that that make if you're doing costumes
for like a video or something that makes
sense
yeah i i've done that for sure target
has a great target and walmart have
probably the best return policies yeah
you can do whatever to the the products
and you can bring them back and they
always just look at the receipt and then
they look at you and then they're like
all right whatever
yeah cut the deal yeah yeah all right
pretty good i'll give you that how do
you feel about uh when's the last time
or do you partake in
um if you make a purchase with your card
at a store
do you get cash back
yeah before before the pandemic i i
almost always got cash back
how much oh the a lot of times the limit
the 40
limit oh yeah that's a bad look you're
getting cash back at like the 7-eleven
or the cvs or something dude i would
sometimes
i would sometimes go to the grocery
store to avoid going to the bank where
i'd buy a pack of gum and i'd be like
i need 40 bucks oh my god can i get 300
small bills on your way to a wedding
yeah
holy [ __ ] dude that's next level trash
i do i literally the cash before before
the thing with like you know paper money
and stuff like that like i
always enjoyed getting cash back at
grocery stores and
and the grocery store that i would go to
also
coincidentally had a bank attached to it
so sometimes i would
do my uh my grocery shopping and then i
would go to the bank afterwards it's
like an all-in-one trip
sit down and get an auto loan real quick
yeah oh man we got we have them too in
philly man
and the burbs like some like random bank
that like
you know it's not even chemical bankers
yeah not even a nationwide chain is
attached to you're like what who the
[ __ ]
getting their ira done in this [ __ ]
house
i like how those sorry
oh i said i like how those those those
banks are like ah the kentucky huts work
right that works
let's put them in a freaking grocery
store exactly yeah yeah
someone's sitting there like a
watermelon and open up a checking
account oh
[ __ ] um all right i got one have you
ever
had anything airbrushed
non-ironically because that is the most
garbage
way to paint anything you got a jean
jacket that has a [ __ ]
airbrushed unicorn on the back like a
tasmanian devil or something
i um i went to um there's an amusement
park
in iowa um that's called um
it's not a good start to a story it's
called trashies
right it's called fun it's fun something
the one in the one in kansas city is
called worlds of fun and i've gotten
stuff
airbrushed either there or we went to uh
in iowa as a kid we got we would get
like the t-shirts
i had a i had a hat that was airbrushed
that was like
i literally wore it once or twice
because it was like the most disgusting
looking
sure like you're so juiced up as a kid
that you want that that you're like oh
this is going to be so sick
and then you like wear it outside of the
walls yeah
and you're like oh i look like a loser
you do that that barely makes it to the
car sometimes you're like
what the [ __ ] was i thinking all hopped
up on funnel cake and cotton candy
no [ __ ] it's like in field of dreams you
get to the edge of that amusement park
you turn into an old man [ __ ] that yeah
dude airbrush is tough dude do you have
any tattoos
i don't have any tattoos no tattoos okay
my brother and sister do but i do not
have tattoos
all right so any members of the family
that have tattoos are any of them disney
characters
looney tune characters anything like
that
um no they're all like um
like my brother has like a tribal tattoo
on his uh
it's understandable it was of the time
it was sure and it's tough yeah i'll
give him that
yeah and then um he's got like a
i think he's got like a cross somewhere
on um near his collarbone
now and then my my sister has like a
peace heart sign tattoo my mom has uh
uh butterfly uh uh tattoos
on her we gotta meet your mom yeah she
[ __ ] sounds cool
i gotta be honest she's so cool
did she [ __ ] take a hard left out of
the church i love it
holy [ __ ] uh growing up did you have any
uh beaded curtains that separated rooms
any beaded curtain doorways
can't say i did on that one no that's
good
i gotta be honest i just suggested
beaded curtains to my wife like
a month i don't know what i was thinking
she was like she literally looked at me
like we were about to get [ __ ]
divorced
hey you [ __ ] start reading tarot
cards in there
yeah dude be the curtains are a gateway
drug dude
next thing you know i'm doing mushrooms
with my daughter against a gateway to
weird right there you get those things
next thing you know you have the candles
that just burn onto the table with no
candle holder
holy [ __ ] all right did uh has your
family ever owned a chia pet
oh a hundred percent hundred percent
hundred percent the trashiest of the
plants
oh yeah yeah what'd you have what
the generic one we didn't have the guy
one that that one turned into like what
the bob ross kind of looking guy
kind of with the throne he had like a
big nose we had the different
animal ones like okay i think it was
like a pig or something or like a
i don't even remember it was like it was
some kind of animal
we had one or two of the different
animal ones yeah that's a tough look
what was the uh what was the actual pet
situation growing up would you guys have
pets when you were a kid
um we did uh we had a
smirk there's something up with this
what kind of gun
we had we had rabbits at one point we
had rabbits uh named uh
um buttercup and sunken
and uh outdoor rabbits and outdoor
rabbits
and my aunt over fed them while we were
gone and killed them
like while we were on a trip like if you
over feed them that they don't have the
thing in their mind where they stop
eating so they literally eat until they
they
asphyxiate and they're dead i got that
too
couple more weeks i got that um i think
so we so we had like a golden retriever
but they kept knocking down my sister so
we had to get rid of it and then we uh
we've had different
we had we've had different wiener dogs
and i've had a ton of turtles throughout
my life i've had tons of turtles
turtles are tough i have them they smell
they can get smelly turtles can be real
dude the turtle pee
i can't even describe to people how bad
that smell is
turtle pea is one of the worst smells in
the world well i have one in a like in
an aquarium with like rocks like colored
rocks and those rocks
still like i can still smell that
disgusting
it was in the garage the garage smelled
for a decade it's pretty gnarly yeah
he's a turtle guy
yeah turtle guy with chia pets that is a
tough look
watkins i i had five turtles at once
what yeah i had like a uh like a
i had one giant red-eared slider
and then what the [ __ ] is that talking
about them like they're muscle cars
no different turtles snapper that's it
of course
yeah i got a red herring it's got a
nitro booster on them
i got a blue prairie turtle uh holy a
red slider that's
[ __ ] how much was that
oh dude man you if you're paying for a
turtle you're doing it wrong brother
man you can't you got them free down the
creek
yeah dude we had i at both houses that i
grew up at creeks
right behind him would you ever say
crick
like instead of come on my dad would but
i no but i like
there's enough like of the kansas like
stereotype where i'm like i'm above this
yes that's good that's good yeah yeah
but you got five turtles so you're not
above much because if you found them in
a crick or not that's five turtles at
the house
[ __ ] great uh let's go a little
exotic here uh back to food did you ever
uh in your home have the cooking device
known as the walk
oh your parents ever go through a walk
phase
because mine didn't it was real trashy
i don't think so we just had a lot of
crock pots but we didn't have like uh
any
any walks crock pots nice crock pot very
classy
very classy especially in the fall and
winter
a nice hearty stew ah come home you
smell that
that's americana right there boys and
girls okay this is this is a this is a
new
one have you ever had a padded or wooden
toilet seat
uh my nana did and my grandma did yeah
the padded ones yep
yeah they they um the wooden ones they
were like
this weird cushion thing where like dude
like there'd be like when you got up
from it there'd be like a
a sweat ring around the uh
the the little cushion that was like
really weird you would sit on it would
be like
you like hear the air leaving the
cushion yeah yeah it's like
decompressing like an air mattress that
you leave out too long in the
in the living room yeah the thing is
those were like porous they weren't
sterile like the plastic ones are like
you know kind of sterilish like they're
they're wipeable they're not porous
dude you're like sitting on like a
recliner those things were dicey
yeah and the wooden ones i remember
having somebody had a wooden one that
but they had it forever and it like
split so you would literally get like a
splinter in your ass when you took a
do-do
it's [ __ ] trash it made me think
about it yeah that's pretty bad
christina hutchinson
we were just at her place she has one
that's what made me think of it but she
lives by herself so that's a little clan
like if you live by your if you're a
a woman in your 30s living by yourself
you can get what you can get away with a
wooden toilet sure a guy
nice too yeah yeah what about the uh i
don't know if i ever asked you this
you know the the little rug part that
goes firmly
up against the toilet you ever have that
yeah almost every toilet that i've ever
yeah yeah those things are
soaked with urine yeah yeah that's a
tough you gotta stay on top of them
yeah i know my mom would always be uh
washing those yeah and then like dude it
was so gross like
like she would like wash it because she
knew that like as little kids that we
would be peeing on it sure but like you
turn it over and the white side would be
freaking disgusting yeah yep yeah
it's tough you didn't realize as a kid
the first time i realized that those
things just held pay was when like i was
in college and we bought one for our
house
and then like after three days i'm like
this is covered and paid like my mom was
cleaning it that much you know
oh you you don't realize how much your
mom cleaned
yes when you were a kid until you get
your own place and then you're like
oh my mom there's pee everywhere
wasn't it the best though when you came
home and the house was [ __ ] spotless
for some reason she just did such a good
job everything when the lines in the
carpet from the vacuum cleaner
maybe a fresh airwick candle or
something like that it's trash
spray the febreze oh yeah fresh bottle
of [ __ ] hawaiian febreze
all right i got another quick one do you
know how to tie a tie
i do know how to tie a tie okay nice
respectable have you ever been on
have you ever been on a closed tube
water slide
so many times that's a water slide
the closed tube that's that's different
that's a water i mean you go to a water
park do you go
you're going through the dark tunnels
when's the last time you were at a water
park
and or amusement park uh
i was technically
either i went to a water park in texas
it was either
towards the beginning of this year or
last year have you ever had your picture
taken while you're on a roller coaster
have you ever bought the picture dude i
haven't bought it but i've snagged some
free pics okay
yeah baby that's the garbage way
they yell at you like no pictures like
[ __ ] get out of here they get real
mad
they get really pissed
that's pretty good we went to a disney
brunch uh when we were in hawaii
and they you know you get to take
pictures with the with the characters
and then when you're eating they come
around they say oh you guys want to buy
the pictures you're like hey what the
[ __ ] you're talking about we were taking
pictures
with the [ __ ] cell phone over your
shoulder so you got me coming and going
for the [ __ ]
prime rib station you think i'm [ __ ]
throwing out 40 for another picture with
goofy
it ain't happening i don't know who you
think you're talking to um
all right this was a big one this was a
big one online this week did you cut
did your mom cut your sandwiches
diagonal or horizontal
wow great question diagonal for sure wow
down the middle
that's a class move that doesn't cost
any money i don't know why moms don't
get it
i was a down the middle thing and it
just
i mean you would you would go to
somewhere i would do the have sometimes
and it just feels like a hunk of meat
when it's just cut
down the middle i see i like that i feel
with the diagonal you're getting ripped
off
because those bites on the end there's
nothing
no dude you're nuts where'd the rest of
it go it's all over his face
yeah there's no cheese in here who ate
all of it
who ate my food
[Laughter]
the fat guy with amnesia do you know how
to drive a bobcat or
any um earth-moving equipment
no to that uh-uh excellent okay pretty
good
yeah have you ever had a rat tail
no but i had to mull it in college for a
little bit
like ironically or you just didn't
realize an ironic thing okay
yeah i i was working in morning radio
and uh we did this promo to raise
uh money for this uh dog shelter that um
they uh auctioned off my forehead as
rental space
and uh what a morning zoo [ __ ]
campaign i know right they put a
temporary tattoo
on my forehead and they cut my hair i
had long hair at the time they cut it
into a mullet so they cut it into a
mullet and then i had
uh it said like autumn oak apartments
with the phone number on my forehead for
like
five days like it was like a temporary
tattoo that
freaking i was worried it got to the
point where i was like is this on my
forehead like for good
like he's in calculus class [ __ ] red
oak apartments or whatever
dude i so i moved to real estate
it probably did it probably did people
hated me they saw me from like
across the room they're like who is this
guy yeah a lot of jerk off moves
oh holy [ __ ] oh my god that's [ __ ]
awesome
uh have you ever been involved in a dunk
tank and or a ball pit
yes uh dunk tank yes and then
um ball pit i mean i just i used to
get in ball pits at mcdonald's all the
time
and chuck e cheese yeah yeah chuck e
cheese alright because that's what
you're going for so it makes sense but
ball pit at mcdonald's they say i used
to love those dudes i love the good play
please so dirty
but like dude you would scoop stuff up
and it was like you'd find
baby socks and stuff oh yeah like an old
nugget and stuff floating around in
there
yeah it was pretty yeah pretty bad one
baby sock will creep you the [ __ ] out oh
yes dude a dunk tank is the trashiest of
all
[ __ ] amusement park attractions i was
in oh yeah it is great though man that
water is ice cold
crisp and cool [ __ ] going that thing
i remember thinking they had one at like
for like a soccer fundraiser or
something we were kids for like the
soccer teams or the group or something
and i remember like they're gonna be a
dunk tank and i'd be like someone's dad
was doing it i'm like that guy is
like mr robinson is so [ __ ] cool how
lucky is
he gonna be in the i remember looking at
my dad be like you [ __ ] dork why
aren't you getting the dunk tank
remember you got nervous when you were
throwing the whole thing like it was the
world series
meanwhile dude i i i would go to one
that like um
it was like a clown that would roast you
while
you did it they were big and if you
didn't yeah and if you didn't
you know if you didn't hit it they would
like they had free range to crush you
it was the 90s so it was like [ __ ]
like pc was
out the window yeah yeah dude there was
one in the wildwood new jersey boardwalk
which is like the [ __ ] scum of the
scum and there was this guy would get
all bombed up and smoked cigs
and just sit there and he had his face
painted and he called
dude if you have if you were fat you got
it white
black asia dude you got the [ __ ]
worst of it
so bad he was so mean and so cutting
that he had to leave with police escort
to get out he would
leave under the boardwalk because dudes
would wait around he would just say [ __ ]
yeah and dudes would be like well i'm
gonna kick your ass when you get out of
here
yeah you're not gonna kick [ __ ] you
[ __ ] losers oh yeah and then you
would
you would finally get them you would
finally get them and it was rigged
like you know how they had the bullseye
the bullseye was like you really had to
hit like a pinpoint on it to get it
yeah and he would [ __ ] fall he'd be
smoking a sick he'd fall in the water to
get up and go high and dry
it was my favorite [ __ ] thing in the
world they also have a button
on the inside did you know that no
to what a lot of them have a button so
they like if you
are close enough you can hit your own
button
to collapse the seat so basically if
somebody if you're wanting somebody to
feel like they actually got it
and if even nick's like the end of it
they can press
right right wow buddy the fact that you
even know that that's the next level
trash dude
hold on out of the dunk tank game yeah
he's like well if you're in an expensive
one there's actually a hair trigger what
do you got a clarkman is that what
you're working with there
it's got the european dump trap right
it's a semi-automatic it's a
pretty beautiful model the paperwork's a
little questionable on it but
all right here's another hot button
issue that's been going around the ru
garbage community i'm going to ask you
either as a kid or now
how do you feel about brushing your
teeth
in the shower
i can't get behind it thank you thank
you yeah
it's something about uh i've tried it
i've tried it multiple times and there's
something about it where it just feels
it just feels too gross to me yes thank
you thank you
there's something about like the water
of just you going
like letting that water it's warm and
stuff
it's just not the right temperature and
and also
you feel kind of like insane
brushing your teeth naked i don't know
why but like
if you're naked and brushing your teeth
you're like why am i
why am i doing this
psycho just like like you're naked
you're just looking you know i never
thought of that holy [ __ ] that seals the
deal you should not be naked brushing
your teeth
felt i'm not going to take stuff you're
looking at yourself in the mirror like
patrick bateman yeah
am i going insane that's [ __ ]
good that's good how do you feel about
public
venmo transactions or are you a
gentleman
and do your venmo business privately
well it's funny you ask that because uh
on
i do this podcast with uh tony
hinchcliffe kill tony every week
yeah and brian redband he gets upset
with me because
i publicly plug my venmo on there
okay like i hold up a sign that says
venmo at jeremiah
watkins on it the whole thing and i
never
i never do my transactions publicly
they're all private
but i publicly plug my venmo that's okay
you try to make a little money you're a
[ __ ] performer the kid's trying to
wet his beak
i get it there you go there he is
away you know what i'm saying what'd you
say dylan so speaking of that my venmo
is uh
no one send him money yeah if you're do
if you do it publicly if it's just like
for
beer for pizza winky winky it's like all
right we get it you're [ __ ] buying
coke
we don't we don't even know right keep
your business private
people try to request me as friends on
venmo and that that's always weird to me
that's weird
it's a transaction yeah at drug deals
you don't
say hey can we become friends it's like
yeah what are you doing later type thing
yeah we're done with it it's a
give-and-go strictly business
keep it moving what do you got kip
i think i only got one or two more here
um
i got a question for you guys fire away
lay it on us
did you have spam or vienna sausages
growing up
here's the here's the ruling on that
it's trash um now obviously you get out
to the midwest i understand vienna
sausage can become a way of life
but in fact the only classy choice
is spam because of its military heritage
that's it ah it was that a necessity and
not to bring up hawaii again but over in
hawaii
they love spam and they do a lot of
really good things with it that's
absolutely fantastic
vienna sausage it just tastes like [ __ ]
it's all
trash it's canned meat there's no bites
messages and
[Laughter]
your honor
[Laughter]
actually the uh little smokey from
hillside did you grow up eating it is
that why you ask
oh yeah that's why i asked because i i
was curious like what your guys
consensus is on that if that's
considered
like a trashy thing or not it's for sure
trash
yeah it's for sure come on we're all
friends here listen you should
you should only buy your meat in like if
it's frozen
for whatever but if you should really be
buying meat fresh
sliced or cut and wrapped to consume not
tanned it shouldn't be canned really if
you think
[Music]
no but i i have bought aldi meat
recently
what's aldi meat what i like an old one
i know yes
it's like it's their it's their packaged
meat that's like
their like brand like lunch meat or like
a chicken breast
lunch meat i pre-packaged lunch meat i
actually have it right here it's the
second question that i didn't get to
pre-package lunch meat is trash dude i
disagree dude i
eat that all the time yeah it's probably
good but it's [ __ ]
garbage dude like they sell those they
sell the fresh slice thing 10 feet away
from where you're getting it it's in
it's in the
it's in the they cost 50 cents more dude
yeah because it's but it's a thousand
dollars better
what's dude you take that sweaty lunch
meat out of that [ __ ]
tube i don't know so your selections
aren't that bad
you don't pat down your deli meat before
you put it on the bread with
with paper towels what the [ __ ]
yeah because it's trash dude if you get
a half a pound of turkey
sliced in like a gentleman at the
counter how
[ __ ] god intended you don't need to
pat it down it's got the perfect amount
of liquid on it
god he's patting down you need to get
off this podcast and call a lawyer i'll
tell you that right now
you're patting down your lunch meat
oh my god dude that's crazy your wife
lets you pat down lunch meat that's nuts
that's crazy she's gonna ask you if you
didn't want me to eat the aldi mate
yeah no she won't eat the she won't eat
the aldi meat
she won't eat the aldi meat no she
sounds like a smart she's a classy woman
yeah and that's good it's always smart
from the bay area
yeah okay yeah very nice maybe i
like it um all right i think i got one
i think the pre-packaged lunch lunch
meet was it to be honest i just want to
hit him with two of the uh
yeah have adam two of the standards um i
don't know where this is gonna go
but uh we have a rule here about keeping
certain things in certain places in the
home
um where at the watkins household now
do you keep your ketchup is it in the
cabinet or in the refrigerator
it's in the refrigerator okay okay
there's animals out there keeping it
like above the microwave and how about
your
syrup do you keep your maple syrup in
the refrigerator or in the cabinet
that's in the cabinet nice this guy's
making he's making a fourth quarter run
right now all right here we go
uh growing up did you have milk with
dinner
so many times so many times
dude i i still drink milk with dinner
i probably had it earlier this week i
love you man i love milk with dinner
dinner's trash [ __ ] too but i got bad
news for you you're [ __ ] garbage
it's trash there's milk for dinner it's
trash
oh i love it too man don't you like it
with spaghetti
nice cold glass of milk food spaghetti
oh with lasagna are you kidding me
that's so
freaking good so that's everybody yuck
everybody that does it loves pasta and
tomato sauce and milk like that's the
combination everybody loves
also milk with the deli meat sandwiches
with a good
chip like a frito or a potato chip
absolutely
good i got another one i got another one
for you why
why we're in the while we're well we're
in this universe while we're in this
trashy
welcome to the revolution my friend uh
do you put the chips on the sandwich
sometimes i usually with with the
diagonals it's usually i sprinkle them
in between
you sleep you're still cutting diagonal
wow that's pretty close
this kid's bonko's i'll tell you that
these la guys i don't know what's going
on down is up up
down i don't know what's happening
you're still cutting them sideways
when you put it on the plate do you set
it like on top of one another like like
like
presentation you played it real nice no
no
but i do you know uh they they do
perfectly make a triangle so you put the
chips
in between that's very nice wow that's
pretty good
unfortunately that's not gonna save you
here my
uh jeremiah watkins i gotta say 100
percent
garbage forget about it i wouldn't say a
hundred
he's got some you know a 70
70 garbage what was what was where where
are you on the fence this is like it's
like
it's like a movie script oh i forgot
yeah i forgot about the guns and the atf
the guns the doomsday preppers yeah i
forgot
y2k i forgot about the y2k okay okay
okay
oh trash [ __ ] absolutely welcome but
you're in good company you're in great
company brother i'll tell you that
[ __ ] you won my heart you and i got
to get together have some lasagna no
the next time you're in town dude i want
to make that happen immediately
i'll do it against digital put it behind
a paywall buddy thank you so much for
doing the show is there anything you
want the folks out there to know before
we let you get out of here
um i've just got a bunch of great stuff
on my youtube youtube.com
jeremiahwatkins um i've got like a
breakfast show on there where i eat
breakfast with friends and strangers
and my podcast jeremiah wonders is a lot
of fun
and uh jeremiah stand up on social media
and then in the next i think in the next
month i don't know when this comes out
i'll be uh announcing some special uh
uh related to my stand up that i'm very
excited about that i can't uh
talk about quite yet but it's on friday
very awesome awesome
yeah this will be uh uh monday i think
they're gonna be out monday for the
general public yeah
yeah okay okay cool so i've got some fun
stand-up related news coming in like
within the next month i'll be able to
talk about it awesome and i just want to
say i know i know jeremiah is known for
a lot of things uh but your stand-up's
absolutely fantastic the one time that
we worked together i think was maybe
last year
you were at new york comedy club i was
hosting it was a pretty packed show but
it was they were pretty tough
this kid goes up there and [ __ ]
absolutely
demolishes nice so [ __ ] fantastic job
brother you're doing great
i appreciate that brother thank you man
kippy what do you thank you guys so much
for having me
of course pal just uh business as always
please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes
uh full video available on youtube you
can subscribe there as well and if you
want to subscribe to gas digital network
use promo code ayg
we get to wet our beaks you save a
couple of bucks everybody wins
check me out on social media kevin ryan
comedy yes sir at holy on ice on twitter
and foleygrams on instagram we love you
guys and we'll see you next week
jeremiah thank you again brother